foreign
companies thus far we've deployed over
50 million in capital and hopefully
we'll be doing a lot more in the next
over the next few years
Dune is a venture fund that invests in
games and technologies that expand and
disrupt games
I dropped out of school when I was 18 to
join an early stage startup called
Galaxy digital company did really well
went public and as part of that we ended
up building internally a gaming division
that ended up investing in some of the
best companies in games and so I took
all that experience for the last few
years and decided to go on my own start
my own fund honestly it's very scary but
also really empowering it was really
really exciting to uh for the first time
do something in my my vision basically
there are advantages and disadvantages
to being this age Adventure I think the
core Advantage is a lot of the founders
you work with who are really brilliant
are sometimes 18 19 20 21 they're really
really young and they come from this
entirely digitally native world and so I
grew up playing games so I understand
games like still play games all day long
and so being the age I am doing what I
do is I think specifically really
helpful
foreign
the biggest challenge about running Dune
so far has been building our brand and
presence in the space getting Founders
to want to work with us and reach out to
us when they want to go raise their
pre-seed C Series a is way more
difficult than I ever imagined it to be
and it takes a lot of time and it's it's
not only about Twitter or online
presence it's a lot about reputation
working with other investors working
with other Founders I found that the
biggest thing we have ever done for
brand building is just having a great
relationship with our Founders because
Founders talk to other Founders and
spread the word I think by having such
intimate knowledge about our companies
and having such great relations with
their Founders and we're already seeing
this we have exclusive access to
follow-on investments into the companies
we have bigger ownership and overall
have a way deeper understanding of the
companies
whenever we meet a Founder that has a
very unique backstory or very unique
view of the world that's that's what we
back I take dozens of pitches a day
hundreds a week and a lot of these
pitches are mostly the same same pitch
same thesis I've consistently found that
the companies that we backed I would
have never imagined us to head back in
the beginning because the thesis was so
different from what I viewed the world
as but that's what's exciting about
these companies right and it requires a
very unique background and thesis and
talent to go build these companies so
that's what we look for
one of our first really big Investments
was a company called metal TV they're
now one of the largest social platforms
for gamers they let you
clip moments and games the entire thesis
around this was
every day we take moments in our
physical lives Instagram Snapchat Tick
Tock we have no tools similar for the
digital world but yet we spend so much
time in the playing video games five
plus hours a day and so
the idea is that we're building the
Instagram or Tick Tock for for games
right the the tool to enable Gamers
across the world which there are
billions of to share their moments with
their friends and connect people across
the world
we won't sell Dune because this is what
I'm going to spend the rest of my life
doing I'm not too worried about Legacy I
want to to make sure that we
make as much impact as possible with our
Founders and if we do that over the next
few decades I think that will be the
Legacy if I can discover some incredible
young Talent as we've been doing over
the last few years I'll be very happy
[Music]